so here we are in the Alfie Evans case
continues to take priority in Great
Britain parkland survivor Akaka Shoob is
interviewed by the police for going to a
gun range and a feminist once your
second grader to learn about
transgenderism no I'm not joking this is
the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
so we have a lot to get to today and the
Southie Evans case in Britain truly is
astonishing and it is accompanied by
British law enforcement focusing in
areas where let's just say they probably
should not be putting their law
enforcement focus we'll get to all of
that in just a second first I want to
say thanks to our sponsors over at
Winged so you know you've taken a little
bit of time to bring yourself out over
the new years and now you're in the
middle of the year and you're thinking
yourself boy I could really use
something to relax well that's what wink
is for also it is great for when you
have to go over to a family member's
house and you don't know what bottle of
wine to bring you don't know anything
about wine all you know is that you need
something better than Manischewitz
grapes grape juice with some sort of
coughing syrup inside and so you need a
good wine well that's what wink is for
wink makes it easy to discover a great
wine winks wine experts select lens
match to your taste personalized for you
shipped right to your door starting just
13 bucks a bottle there's nothing like
coming home into a box of delicious wink
wine selected just for you it is the
best day of your mom so here's how it
works you go over to wink and then you
try their palate profile quiz you answer
simple questions their average store
clerk wouldn't ask or translate into a
recommendation like how do you take your
coffee and how do you feel about
blueberries and then they send you wines
curated to your taste the more wines you
rate the more personalized your monthly
selections each month there are new
delicious wines right now they're
popular wine is the summer water rose a
so go over and check it out right now at
Tri wink comm slash Bend and you get 20
bucks off your first shipment
let's try blink comm / pen winc t ry
winc comm / pen for $20 off again try
wink comm / Ben so they know that we
sent you alright so I have to say the
the British law enforcement system I
think they have their priorities all
screwed up so I'm going to show you
something that the British law
enforcement system is cracking down on
and then I'm going to show you something
that the british law enforcement system
is something else they are doing and
you'll see the difference right away so
they're obviously spending heavy amounts
of time right now cracking down on
people who violate traffic ordinances so
this has become a very popular clip
online the the local police in britain
tweeted out that this one guy who was
speeding and violating the law and had a
laser jammer I guess that was aimed at a
traffic camera he was flipping off the
traffic camera always in North Yorkshire
North Yorkshire
police they tweeted out top top tip if
you want to stay out of trouble don't do
what this driver did and swear in our
mobile safety cameras while driving past
in a car fitted with the laser jammer
today this guy is beginning eight months
in jail for perverting at the course of
justice and then they released a video
of this of this fellow who is who's
driving with his finger up in the air
flipping off the camera
so it's so you know this this is where
they're putting their focus now what's
amazing about this is that obviously
they're not just mad that the guy had a
laser jammer which apparently is illegal
it perverts the court of justice the
they're really upset that he was
flipping off the traffic cameras so this
is where they're putting heavy focus
other places where the Brits are putting
a heavy focus right now so they just
gave an 800 pound fine to a guy who had
his girlfriend's pug make a Nazi salute
on YouTube okay so here's the story
there's this guy in Britain who's a
YouTube kind of lols guy all he does is
make funny YouTube videos and he doesn't
like his girlfriend's pug dog and so his
girlfriend is constantly going on and on
about how cute this pug dog is so while
she was out of town he trained the Pug
dog to give a Nazi salute every time he
said gas the Jews okay so it's
ridiculous it's comedy maybe it's funny
to something not funny to others the
brits find this guy 800 pounds he barely
escaped a jail sentence for training a
pug dog to do a joke Nazi salute
so that's what the British authorities
are focused on here's what they are not
focused on they're not focused on rape
gangs in Britain according to the UK
independent grooming gangs abused more
than 700 women and girls around
Newcastle with arrogant persistence
after police appeared to punish victims
while letting the perpetrators walk free
a case reviews found the report into the
response by authorities to child sexual
exploitation found that before a large
scale police operation was launched in
officers actions were sending an
unhelpful message to perpetrators
investigators said the abuse could not
be stopped without work to understand
the profiles motivations and cultural
influences of perpetrators after finding
similarities with grooming in Rotherham
Rockdale and oh and Oxford and Oxford um
here is the reason why they've been so
soft on these grooming gangs it's
because these grooming gangs are largely
Muslim men and so every time they're in
the press they referred to a South Asian
men they the religion is never mentioned
we're supposed to pretend that
unassimilated radical Muslim immigration
into various European societies
no impact but the Brits are not focused
on that no instead they are ensuring
that a child must die so the big story
out of the UK today is actually the
story of Alfie Evans and this is very
similar to the case you'll remember of
Charlie guard Charlie guard was a an 11
month old baby who had a degenerative
brain condition and the British courts
ruled that the hospital could Trump his
parents wishes his parents wanted to
bring him to the United States for
experimental treatments and the British
Court system ruled at the hospital which
had testified that would be against the
child's interests for him to be moved to
the United States for the possibility of
further treatment they ruled instead
that the kid had to be removed from life
support and the parents had to watch him
die well now they're doing the same
thing to alfie Evans who's 2 years old
suffers from an undiagnosed brain
condition that has left him in the semi
vegetative state and he's been ordered
removed from life support by the British
government over the wishes of his
parents his parents want to ship him to
Italy and put him under the care of the
Vatican Hospital his parents wanted to
move him there to pursue palliative
measures but the British Court ruled
that that would not be an Alfie's best
interest instead would be an alfea's
best interest who died which is an
amazing ruling right the ruling that it
would be better for you to die does not
seem like a medical ruling it seems like
a values ruling it seems like a ruling
in favor of euthanasia as opposed to a
ruling in favor of the possibility of a
medical miracle or in favor of the
possibility that maybe some doctor knows
something that you don't so they removed
him from life support pursuant to the
order of a British Court and then Alfie
continued to breathe on his own for 15
hours after being disconnected from life
support they didn't think that was gonna
happen they thought he died as soon as
he was removed from life support the
hospital still has not reconnected him
to oxygen machines even though he has
lived for 15 hours without the oxygen
machines there's supposed to be another
court hearing today and Alfie Evans is
dead has it has talked to the media
about all this because I'm still
fighting I'm still fighting and so
Sophie appeared so to the ambassador of
Italy if these doctors
my son's life to be done by the audience
if these amazing my son and I'm
confident he will decide I've been a
facade every minute of every day no but
my son's life lies in jelly beans hands
and he's a member of Italy my son
belongs to Italy and I'm not stopping
this fight until I look to Sami
okay this is so the the Italian
government gave alfie is Hallion
citizenship so that they could issue a
an effort to save his life in the
European High Court you know the United
States government tried to do that I
believe with Charlie guard it was
something I was encouraging Congress
people do is give him honorary
citizenship so they could make a case
that he ought to be removed from Britain
and headed over to the United States
Pope Francis has tweeted moved by the
prayers and immense solidarity shown
little Alfie Evans I renew my appeal
that the suffering of his parents may be
heard and that their desire to seek new
forms of treatment may be granted again
all this comes down to is in Britain
they believe that in a conflict between
the parents and the hospital in a case
of controversy not in a case where
clearly you know the parents are
refusing a life-saving treatment for
example but in a case where the parents
wants who saved the life then the
hospital's want the kid to die they're
saying the hospital still have full
range over what exactly should happen to
the kid which is just an amazing amazing
argument amazing anti life bureaucratic
argument you know evil comes in a lot of
forms in terms of government evil comes
in the form of tyranny evil comes in the
form of communism evil comes in the form
of governments that they take a
hands-off position with regard to murder
evil also comes in the form of
bureaucratic niceties
you know bureaucrats who sit atop the
top of the world in their little offices
in Britain and decide whether a child
should live or die
because they know more than the parents
do or because the hospital
administrators say they know more than
the parents did the British government
actually had to place 30 officers around
the hospital to prevent protesters from
attempting to move the baby those
protestors were attempting to storm the
hospital and remove the baby and by the
way this father I believe under an under
natural right has every right to grab
that baby and make a break for it and
push everyone out
his way it's his baby it's his kid and
he's not something to kill the kid he is
attempting to save the kid the hospital
is attempting to kill the kid it's just
an amazing thing now here's my question
where is the American left in all of us
so the American right is saying you got
to save this kid's life you got to do
everything possible to save this kid's
life where's the American left in all
this and the American left it suggests
that abortion is fine because just a
cluster of cells but once the baby is
born it's no longer just a cluster of
cells where are they for all of this the
American left that cheered I remember
there's a movie called John Key who came
out in 2002 has moved with Denzel
Washington and the movie was about a
black kid who had an enlarged heart and
they didn't have the money to pay for
his heart surgery and so John Q took
over the hospital with a gun and tried
to hold the doctors hostage to perform
the surgery on his son and this movie
was was praised to the skies by liberals
because liberals said this is what the
American Health System is like well in
this particular case this is not about
who's paying for what the parents aren't
asking the British government to pay for
anything in this particular case you've
got a father who is trying to remove his
son from a hospital to save the son's
life and the American left is utterly
silence when it comes to free market
economics in the health care system in
the United States then they're very
upset when it comes to actual
bureaucratic murder happening in the UK
then the American left just goes
completely silent which says to me that
this has a lot less to do with how they
think the health care system should be
run and a lot more to do with how they
value human life that if the baby has
some sort of degenerative brain
condition that this is a baby that is
not deserving of life you can see the
short leap from here to the eugenics of
the left in the early 20th century it is
not a long leap by any means whatsoever
it really is horrifying and to show how
horrifying it is and just remember this
week the British royal family Princess
Kate and her husband Prince Harry they
had a baby this week and the entire
nation of Britain celebrated and this is
a beautiful thing
of course imagine if god forbid god
forbid one of the members of the royal
family had a child like Alfie Evans do
you really think do you really think the
royal family would allow the hospital to
kill the child in violation of the will
of the parents do you really think that
would happen or is there a class
differentiation even in the system where
we pretend there is no class
differentiation is there a difference
between royal and rich in Britain and
being poor and in the clutches of the
National Health Service the answer is of
course there is one
the government gets to say what sort of
care you deserve and what sort of care
you must be provided they also get to
say what sort of carrot you don't
deserve and what is best for the chat is
best for the child so there are folks
who say this has nothing to do with
nationalized health care because it
isn't a question of rationing but
inherently it is a question of how a
ration system considers the value of
human life because they do have to make
calls as to what is best for particular
human lives and they also have to decide
whether they think a human life is worth
living at a particular point and they've
decided this kid is suffering and that
his suffering is not worth trying to
preserve his life which isn't their
decision in the first place it really is
horrifying
it really is discussing in this
demonstrative of the difference in value
held between the right and the left when
it comes to saving human lives even even
kids like Alfie Evans it's just it's
devastating it's devastating this kid is
the same age as my own kid and the
thought of the hospital trying to do
this to me with my regard my own kid is
so horrifying I can't imagine a
situation which I would not bring a gun
and try to break my kid out just because
I mean I don't know what the hell the
right the hospital has to tell a parent
what his best interest for their child
when it comes to trying to kill the
child again it's one thing to say that
the kid should be that the kid should be
allowed to get a treatment when the
parents don't want the kid to get a
treatment it is another thing to say the
kid should be deprived of life-saving
support because the hospital thinks
differently in the parent is just
unbelievable well I have more on this
but for that before we get to that first
I want to say thanks to our sponsors
over at up side so you know the fact is
that if you were an astronaut right now
you'd want to be talking to Mission
Control on a regular basis well when you
are traveling you also want to be
talking to Mission Control on a regular
basis or at least you want to have
access to Mission Control if something
should go wrong well that's what up side
comm is for up side comm the folks at up
side are your Mission Control they're
looking out for you every step of the
way
handling any problems that might pop up
they've got a team of specialists
working 24/7 to make sure your flight
hotel and car rental all go off without
a hitch they monitor your trip around
the clock they proactively keep you
posted on everything from if it's gonna
rain to alternative return flights home
in case you want to squeeze in one more
meeting you don't get that level of
service from any of these other travel
sites I know I've used them up side has
the best service I promise we use it
here at the office for easy booking
competitive prices and a team that
always has your back book your next
business trip at upside calm and for a
limited time when you book that first
business trip with upside you'll get a
minimum $100 amazon.com gift card just
go to up side comm slash pen to book
your first business trip that's upside
comm slash pen and you get
at least a $100 amazon.com gift card
when you book that first trip again 600
minimum purchase required 600 our
minimum purchase required while supplies
last you decide for complete details go
to up side that calm slash mana lets
them know we sent you and you get $100
amazon.com gift card when you book your
first trip so go check it out there's no
reason not to had every reason to do so
upside calm slash Ben alright so
speaking of authorities that have
overreached in incredibly dramatic
fashion
so Kyle cashew of who I've become
friendly with the the parkland student
who is pro-gun right for a second
amendment yesterday he called me up and
he told me that he had been called by
school administrators to sit before
school security and be grilled
what exactly did Kyle do that required
school security the armed resource
officers the armed school resource
officers to actually sit across from him
and grill him well he went to the gun
range with his dad which last I checked
in America is not only perfectly legal
but highly recommended people should
learn to shoot with their parents they
should learn to shoot they should learn
how to use a gun they shouldn't know
what a gun safety looks like and Kyle is
a kid who has met with a multiplicity of
senators on both sides of the aisle he's
gone to the White House in an attempt to
push solutions to gun violence he was
called by administrators down to the
office and then he was grilled for 10 to
15 minutes over this over over pictures
of him at a gun range until you tweeted
out it was great learning about our
inalienable right of Second Amendment
and how to properly use a gun this is my
first time ever touching a gun and it
made me appreciate the Constitution even
more my instructor was very informative
I learned a lot Second Amendment is
important and we need to preserve the
Second Amendment and obviously these
sounds like the words of a deeply
violent human being right obviously Kyle
is a threat to public safety it wasn't a
threat to public safety 130 times 30
times the police weren't informed about
the shooter in parkland and weren't able
to remove his guns from him it wasn't a
threat to public safety when the FBI
ignored two separate red flag warnings
about the shooter in Parkland but Kyle
he's a real threat because he went to a
gun range with an instructor and his
father and then tweeted about the value
of the Second Amendment under the
Constitution it really is an
unbelievable thing the fact is that so
here's what Kyle told me yesterday what
he said and what he said was this quote
near the end of third period my teacher
got a call from the office saying I need
to go down and see a mr. Greenleaf I
didn't know mr. Greenleaf but it turned
out he was an armed school
resource officer I went down and found
him and he has courted me to his office
then a second security officer walked in
and sat behind me both began questioning
me intensely first then began berating
my tweet although neither of them had
read it then they began aggressively
asking questions about who I went to the
range with whose gun we used about my
father etc okay so in a second I want to
continue with this account from Kyle
caches because it really is just amazing
here's what he says says they're
incredibly condescending and rude these
officers then a third officer from the
Broward County Sheriff's Office walked
in remember this is the same Broward
County Sheriff's Office that had armed
resource officers on the grounds when
the shooting was happening and they
didn't charge in because supposedly that
would have been too dangerous they let
the kids get shot inside while they did
nothing outside a third officer from the
Broward County Sheriff's Office walked
in and began asking me the same
questions again says Kyle at that point
I asked whether I could record the
interview right which is perfectly
within his rights to ask whether he
could record the interview and they said
no which is always weird to me it's
always weird to me when police officers
say that you can't record a particular
interaction because this is somehow
going to be a serious problem if you're
doing your job you shouldn't be worried
about recording interactions in the
middle of doing a job that is paid for
public dollars he said I asked if I had
done anything wrong again they answered
no I asked why I was there one said
don't get snappy with me do you not
remember what happened here a few months
ago I mean obviously not only does Kyle
remember what happened there a few
months ago he's been stumping for
legislation by working with bill Nelson
a Democrat and Marco Rubio a Republican
in the state of Florida
not only does Kyle know what happened at
Parkland the reason that he went to the
range to learn how to use a gun is
because he believes the guns can be used
in self-defense in defense of others but
the idea of course here is that now that
he's touched a gun the gun has infected
him with the sickness that caused what
happened at Parkland which is just an
insane idea you know all these folks on
the Left who act like touching a gun is
the same as getting bubonic plague is
ridiculous
anyway Kyle continues they continued to
question me aggressively that they could
say nothing I had done wrong they kept
calling me the pro Second Amendment kid
I was shocked and honestly scared it
definitely felt like they were in
tempting to intimidate me I was treated
like a criminal for no other reason than
having gone to the gun range and posted
on social media about it so I've talked
to Kyle again today he says that you
know the situation at the school is not
particularly great for him not only
because the administrators are
relatively unfriendly but other there
are a lot of other students are pro-gun
control who are very upset with him for
speaking out on on these issues
demonstrating once again the leftist
tolerance only extends to people who
agree with you but the fact that
government bureaucracy in the United
States government bureaucracy in Britain
government bureaucracy in Canada the
government bureaucracy has gone so far
that basic freedoms are now being ruled
out of bounds by bureaucrats and we're
all supposed to sit here and take it for
the sake of our safety
so in Britain obviously these two cases
are not similar except for the
bureaucratic incompetence at issue or
the bureaucratic malice at issue you
know obviously in Britain you have this
case with a kid who's now being left to
die by the bureaucrats and in the United
States you have bureaucrats from the
county sheriff's office we're now
grilling a kid for having exercised his
Second Amendment rights up in Canada of
course they have bureaucrats will
prosecute you for speech violations if
you say things that they don't like we
are living in an era when freedom is
going by the wayside in favour of
particularly approved politically
correct views those views range from
guns are bad to a kid doesn't deserve to
live if the kid is is suffering or if
the kid is it has a degenerative brain
condition - if I don't like what you say
I simply get to shut it down this sort
of bureaucratic overreach is
demonstrative of worldview that says
that expertise resides in a select few
who sit at the top of government that is
a lie it is untrue unfortunately is also
the outgrowth of a two hundred and fifty
year project in the West to remove
decision-making possibilities from the
common man and take it up to the top
level again and one of one of the
amazing things about the Enlightenment
is what the Enlightenment said is
basically everybody should have a say in
how the government is run everybody
should have a say in how society
functions and then there's a counter
enlightenment that happened or part of
the Enlightenment itself I don't want to
call the counter enlightenment it was
part of the Enlightenment itself or the
Compton idea the the auguste comte an
idea that there was a select group of
people at the top of a society who knew
better than you how society ought to run
and those people were more enlightened
they were more logical they were more
reasonable they knew the social science
better and therefore they should get to
make the rules that mentality whether it
is applied to economics or whether it is
applied to social life or whether it is
applied to speech is a dangerous
mentality it is a mentality that
threatens your freedom in an
extraordinarily serious way and
threatens our freedom also because those
authorities again are willing to make
political compromises that damage your
rights in every conceivable way they're
willing to make
compromises for their own political
betterment they're willing to to say and
do things in order to gain votes and
gain public credit that they wouldn't do
if it affected their own family it's
it's truly an amazing and sort of a
horrifying thing honestly that they're
that they're constantly willing to make
these sorts of decisions at the
bureaucratic level that affect your life
I'm gonna tell you about some of those
bureaucratic decisions in just a second
we're not allowed to talk about the
bureaucratic decisions I'm about to tell
you about but they are pretty
astonishing first I want to say thanks
to our sponsors over at Tommy John so
Tom Patterson was just a normal dude we
became so frustrated with the fit and
feel of his undergarments he decided to
do something about it he went home and
he sketched up some smarter designs and
a tailor so some pro prototypes and
voila the revolutionary Tommy John
underwear was born that was ten years
ago and since then Tommy John has sold
over 5 million pairs of underwear and
more than half a million dudes have made
the switch to Tommy John so let me tell
you I have time you turn underwear they
are spectacular they are on my butt
right now and they are phenomenal
I had several pairs of them not only are
they great they also go through the wash
and and they come out just the same as
they were when they first came out with
a packet they are worth every penny
Tommy John uses proprietary fabrics and
innovative designs to make sure the legs
never ride up the waistband never rolls
down it's impossible to get a wedgie
with Tommy John's Tommy John's
horizontal click quick draw fly can
change your life as well look even if
you don't believe anything that I've
said it doesn't matter because bottom
line is if you buy it you don't like it
then they have a best pair you'll ever
wear or it's free guarantee so you can
try them for yourself and you have
nothing to lose
join the revolution against
uncomfortable undergarments make the
switch to Tommy John no adjustment
needed hurry - Tommy John's calm now and
use promo code Shapiro's for 20% off
your first order that's Tommy John calm
your first order again promo code
Shapiro's 20% off and again today only
all customers actually get an extra 10%
off all Tommy John limited-edition
anniversary prints so check that out
Tommy John calm pretty spectacular deals
they're handing out to our customers
Tommy John's back on these promo code
Shapiro's for that special deal and to
let them know that we sent you as well
ok so speaking of bureaucratic
incompetence and the effects thereof I
have to talk about this story from
Germany so in Germany Europe is is
really on the brink here and you can see
that the United States is going to
follow if we are not careful so on
Tuesday a guy named Joseph Schuster he's
head of the Central Council of Jews in
Germany told German Jews they should
avoid wearing keep us on the street keep
us a yarmulkes the thing I wear on top
of my head right here after an
arab-israeli was assaulted for wearing a
yarmulke just days ago in social
experiments the Arab Israeli walked
around town in Germany in Berlin and he
was wearing a yarmulke because he didn't
believe all of the talk about
anti-semitism spreading in Europe again
an Arab guy not Jewish he was walking
around wearing the yarmulke and he got
beat up he was hit with a belt buckle
hey the suspects who beat him up was
shouting yahoodi which means Jew in
Arabic the suspect in the assault is a
19 year old Syrian refugee of
Palestinian origin so Joseph Schuster
said explain the people should stop
quote showing themselves openly with a
kippah in a big city setting in Germany
and wear a baseball cap or something
else to cover their head instead so
listen as an Orthodox Jew there are
certain times and I'm travelling where I
will wear a baseball cap specifically
because I know that I'm going into a
more anti-semitic area and I was in
France with my wife a few years ago
there were I would not wear my keeper
openly in France because of all the
anti-semitism in France there have been
cases of people wearing yarmulkes who
are beaten in the streets in in Paris
that was particularly true I remember
there was one subway ride that my wife
and I had to take to the I think it was
the 19th arrondissement the the the 19th
district and my wife was wearing a
necklace that had a Star of David on it
and as we went into the 19th district
you could see that the population was
changing it would became a very heavily
young Muslim male population and for
safety reasons for risk assessment
reasons my wife took her her necklace
and stuffed it inside her sure did that
mean that she was being racist no
because the crime rate against Jews in
particular areas of France is much
higher than in other areas you have to
make a basic risk assessment and that is
not discrimination that is using the
data that is available to you to make a
risk assessment in any case Schuster
explained that people should stop
showing themselves to the keeper they
should wear baseball cap according to
the Associated Press Shuster suggested
three years ago Jews should not wear
skull caps in areas with large Muslim
populations okay so here's the thing
this is one of the things you're not
allowed to talk about so if you're a
member of the bureaucracy in Europe
you're supposed to pretend that the
large increase in Muslim immigration
into Europe has had no cultural impact
this is obviously untrue Jimmy Kartik
has written about it in his book the end
of Europe Douglas Murray has written
about this in in his book that booze
called the death of Europe the change in
the in the culture in Europe thanks to
Muslim immigration
is obvious it is obvious and this is not
suggesting that all Muslim immigrants
into Europe are bad people or
anti-semite it is suggesting that the
percentage of people who are immigrating
to Europe from Muslim lands we're
anti-semites is higher than in the
natural-born population and I am not I'm
not saying this on the basis of no
evidence Hey Johannes do instead of the
University of Oslo writes quote in in a
June 2007 study in 2017 study rather
quote available data on perpetrators
suggest that individuals Muslim
backgrounds stands out among
perpetrators of anti-semitic violence in
Western Europe attitude surveys
corroborate this picture insofar as the
anti-semitic attitudes are far more
widespread among Muslims than among the
general population in Western Europe
hey Polina neuting wrote in The New York
Times last year quote today entering a
synagogue anywhere in Sweden usually
requires going through security checks
including airport like questioning at
times of high alert police officers with
machine guns guard Jewish schools
children of Jewish kindergarten in Malmo
play behind bulletproof glass
not even funerals are safe from
harassment a spokesman from almost
Jewish community put the situation
starkly you quote don't want to display
the Star of David around your neck he
said I just like my wife or as spokesman
for the Goethe burg synagogue put it
it's a constant battle to live a normal
life and not to give in to the threats
but still be able to feel safe according
to this writer in the New York Times
fully 51% of all anti-semitic attacks in
Sweden were perpetrated by Muslims as
opposed to 5% perpetrated by what
right-wing extremists and 25%
perpetrated by left-wing extremists okay
let's be real about this the threat to
Jews in Europe right now is highest from
Muslim immigrants to Europe end of story
it is not coming from these homegrown
right-wing groups okay there's some of
their problems there I'm not a fan of a
lot of these far-right nationalist
groups but let's not pretend that those
far-right nationalist groups are
presenting the same level of risk and
threat to Jewish citizens of Europe as
new Muslim immigrants are if you're
talking about just the group data again
this does not mean every individual
Muslim emigrating to Europe is an
anti-semite who is a danger it does mean
that the increased Muslim immigration
unvetted from areas like Syria is going
to have a market impact on how Jews are
treated on how gay people are treated on
how non Muslim citizens are treated in
Europe which is why you're seeing two
blowback in terms of Europeans reacting
to Angela Merkel importing so many folks
from these areas in Europe these are
serious cultural questions that have to
be
and when you have an entire society that
has decided that assimilation is a
mistake this is what you get and all
these folks who keep claiming diversity
and tolerance and diversity and
tolerance are fine so far as they go but
it can't be tolerance for bad behavior
it can't be tolerance for violent
behavior or for anti-semitism for
example it's amazing
but the bureaucrats in Europe have made
hay over this multicultural issue for
years now hilarious is that every so
often even the same officials who pushed
the multi cultural ethos are forced to
admit that it's not working or Anglo and
Merkel a few years back said
multiculturalism was not working and
that was about the time she decided to
import hundreds of thousands of more
people from an area of the world that
had a very poor history of assimilation
and this is David Cameron the former
Prime Minister of Great Britain he did a
whole speech a few years back about how
multi culturalism had failed in Britain
but all of these authorities all these
bureaucrats believe they know better
than you they believe they know better
than their own citizenry and they
believe that they can change society
simply by wishing that it would be so
and this is a serious problem and
ignoring this problem is not gonna make
it go away what one of the kickbacks
from the multicultural left on this is
that if you talk about the problem that
you are somehow exacerbating violence so
it's I I hesitate even to mention it
because it's so stupid but there's a
shooter named Alexander Bissonnette who
was up in Canada is in Toronto and this
was in 2017 and I announced that his
name was Alexander Bissonnette who had
shot up a mask I did that the reason I
mentioned his name is because he's been
convicted and because it's relevant to
the particular story I generally don't
mention the names of mass shooters on
the program regardless of who they are
in this particular case it matters a
little bit because the left is trying to
claim that I am responsible for the
shooting so the left is claiming I'm
responsible for the shooting be cut
particularly one reporter for a far left
publication in in Toronto because this
human piece of garbage who shot up a
mosque had viewed some of my videos
apparently whether he watched my Twitter
now what's funny about this is that he
watched a lot of people's Twitter
accounts he apparently had retweeted or
liked ninety three of the posts on my
Twitter account I don't know what those
post war I don't know whether they had
to do with feminism I don't know whether
they had to do with economics I'm not
aware that they had to do with Muslims
in particular but in any case the idea
here is that because I say that a higher
percentage of the Muslim population is
radicalized than for example
of the Christian population or the
European percentage large that this is
somehow promoting violence against
Muslims this is insane okay this is
insane you have to recognize the fact on
the ground in order to talk about the
best way that we can all live together
in a society but those facts have to be
facts okay and you're citing facts does
not mean that you are promoting violence
if you go out and you shoot a Muslim
because you are worried about the impact
of radical Islam on the world you are a
piece of crap you're a bad human being
okay I've said this 1,000 times I've
said in this particular rant about the
impact of Muslim immigration in Europe
that I'm not talking about individual
Muslims and whether they're anti-semitic
or not I'm talking about the data that
is being demonstrated in Europe and what
that means for government policy but
what the left has decided to do is if
you mention these two acts because they
don't like these facts being mentioned
because it cuts against their worldview
which is that there are no such thing as
Western values and that everyone from
anywhere should be imported into any
country with no impact on how the
prevailing culture operates they believe
that if you mentioned these facts you
should be cast out of polite society or
you should be blamed for violence now
I've been incredibly consistent on this
particular point if you say something if
you make a political argument and you
are not calling for violence if somebody
does violence in your name you're not
responsible for that violence I said
this about Bernie Sanders and the
Congressional baseball shooting and go
and look it up I talked about this with
regard to President Obama's rhetoric
with regard to cops before the Dallas
police shooting I said this with regard
to black lives matter I said their
arguments are bad their arguments are
creating more conflicts with police
officers but at no point did I suggest
that the President of the United States
Obama was responsible for the shooting
of Dallas cops because he had not called
for the shooting of cops and the same
thing is true here but the left fails to
make that connect deliberately because
with the left wants to do a shutdown
speech their whole goal here is to shut
down speech is to prevent rights because
they believe that the citizens exercise
of the citizens rights is more of a
danger than the bureaucrats shut down of
the citizens rights it's an amazing
thing it's an amazing thing so they'd
prefer to shut down free speech and
blame free speech for the sins of evil
human beings rather than make arguments
against the arguments that I'm making or
make arguments against the arguments
that Kyle cash of is making with regard
to guns or make arguments with regard to
the arguments that are being made about
the value of life in Britain better to
shut all that down better not to have
the Khan
stationed at all better to ignore it
better to pretend none of this is
happening okay so I want to talk about
the the expansion of the bureaucracy in
the United States with regards economics
in just a second first we're gonna have
to go over to Daily wire comm and
subscribe so for $9.99 a month you can
get a subscription to daily wire when
you do you get the rest of our show you
get the rest of Enric Levin's show live
you get the rest of Michael Noel's show
live and if you get the annual
subscription you got this the very
greatest and all beverage vessels the
leftist here's hot or cold tumblr I you
know I think time may be running out to
get one of these so you should probably
do it right now so go and check it out
right now at the annual subscription $99
a year cheaper than our monthly
subscription if you want to lead if you
just want to listen later for free go
over to youtube go over to soundcloud go
over to itunes subscribe and leave us a
review we always appreciate it we are
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
so speaking of the growing bureaucracy
in the United States this is an amazing
story Bernard Bernard Sanders Bernie
Sanders the socialist Vermont loon bag
he has now announced his new plan
his new plan is to give every American a
job apparently after reading some Marc's
smoking some dope eating a pudding cup
while watching the movie Dave he decided
that we would now give every American a
job so what is his plan I love this The
Washington Post reports quote senator
Bernie Sanders will announce a plan for
the federal government to guarantee a
job paying $15 an hour and health care
benefits to every American worker who
wants or needs one embracing the kind of
large-scale government works project the
Democrats have shied away from in recent
decades so it's easy right we just give
it everybody a job you know this is
gonna change anything
you know adding a massive layer of
government bureaucracy to just hand
people jobs do you make work projects
you know dig a hole fill the hole back
in like FDR it won't do any damage sure
exactly that kind of policy led to a
lengthening of the Great Depression by
seven years according to economists from
UCLA but if we do it now won't make any
difference I mean come on well we'll
just tell people we'll go out on the
street if you want a job coming here
we'll pay fifteen bucks an hour for
doing something completely useless and
it'll just be awesome it'll just be
terrific from the best part of the
Washington Post report I do love this
lion quote a representative from Sanders
his office said they had not yet done a
cost estimate for the plan or decided
how it would be funded saying they were
still crafting the proposal of course of
course they hadn't done a cost estimate
for the plan because if you are hiring
tens of millions of American workers
it's going to cost a fortune and you
don't have the money for that yeah I
love that they they haven't decided how
it'd be fun if they know how it's gonna
be funded it's gonna be funded by taxing
the crap out of people who actually earn
in the private sector so we can pay for
an ever-growing ever-present public
sector if full employment were this easy
the Soviet Union would have been a
paradise hey The Washington Post I love
this they show for the plan even though
Bernie Sanders says he has no way to pay
for it he has no idea how much money
it's gonna cost but it's a great plan
let me tell you the best plans all of
the best plans offer fairness fairness
guaranteed by an amount of money I will
not tell you about paid for by people
who might be you but I will pretend that
for purposes of this conversation so we
can pretend that I am full of charity
and lodges say here's how the Washington
Post pushes this stupid plan quote job
guarantee advocates say their plan would
drive up way
by significantly increasing competition
for workers ensuring that corporations
have to offer more generous salaries and
benefits if they want to keep their
employees from working for the
government so the logic here apparently
is that the government will offer you a
job that you get paid more than you
would in the private sector so the
private sector has to pay you more to
compete that will drive up wages it will
also create massive unemployment because
what happens when the businesses can't
afford to compete either they go out of
business or they have to fire their
workers you stupid idiots that's exactly
what happened during the Great
Depression quote this from that UCLA
study in the three years following the
implementation of FDR's policies wages
and 11 key industries averaged 25
percent higher than they otherwise would
have done the economists calculate when
that'd be great according to Bernie
Sanders but unemployment was also 25
percent higher than it should have been
given gains in productivity meanwhile
prices across 19 industries averaged 23
percent above what they should have been
given the state of the economy because
when you drive up the cost of labour you
also drive up the cost of the product
with goods and service is that much
harder for consumers to afford demand
stalled and the gross national product
floundered at 27 percent below where
otherwise might have been so apparently
Bernie Sanders idea is let's copy that
that was awesome also the Washington
Post says that Bernie Sanders this plan
will reduce racial inequality because
black workers face unemployment and
about twice the rates of white workers
as well as gender inequality because
many iterations of the plan call for the
expansion of federal childcare work so
again this is the soft bigotry of low
expectations if you think that black
workers can't compete with white workers
because of their color or women can't
compete with men because of their female
hood this is stupid it's stupid it's the
soft bigotry of low expectations and
it's a welfare program for particular
segments of the population that are
politically powerful but again this is
all about growing the government to the
expense of the private citizen because
remember the private citizen is going to
have to pay for all of this Bernie
Sanders doesn't want to mention that
part because it's awkward if they
actually mention they have to pay for
all of this then people might push back
on the idea that everything in the world
is free now cory booker and kirsten
gillibrand have both embraced Bernie
Sanders his plan because Bernie Sanders
now runs the Democratic Party whatever
you think of the of the chaos inside the
Republican Party at any given point at
least they're not proposing full
employment plans from the movie Dave at
least they're not thinking of Bernie
Sanders as a thought leader my god that
dude I wonder if he has two brain cells
to rub together you know meanwhile
but the the French are visiting the
United States and things are weird
so apparently President Trump and and
the Prime Minister of France the
president of France rather Emmanuel
macron they they planted a tree together
it's a really kind of pathetic tree that
they planted together over at the White
House and it made for some weird
pictures so here here's here's what that
sounded like
they're actually going out to plant a
tree it's a tree that the French
president brought over to the White
House European sisal oak a tree from
France tree comes from the Bela wood in
France the site of a world war two one
battle um so that's weird I mean the
French have really scaled back their
gifts they used to give us the Statue of
Liberty now they give us a branch so
thanks for that guys I said that's
that's pretty amazing
um and the pictures are pretty hilarious
but the real read one of the reasons the
French are over here is because they
want to make the case that Donald Trump
should maintain the horrible awful no
good very bad Iran deal so the Iran deal
of course was signed by President Obama
and the Europeans and it essentially
gave a crapload of money to the Iranians
in exchange for a promise that they
would not go nuclear for ten years they
presumably have been using all of that
money for terrorism and throughout the
Middle East in Syria in Lebanon they've
been handing some of that money to the
to Hamas and they have been expanding
their reach all across the Middle East
with the money handed to them by the
Europeans and by President Obama
meanwhile they've been developing all of
the predicates for nuclear technology
and after ten years they can go nuclear
any time they want John Oliver for some
reason was was making the case on HBO
that the Iran deal should remain in
place I'm not sure why John Oliver is
seen as some sort of political
know-it-all considering the amount he
knows about politics could fit inside a
shoebox but here he is trying to explain
why the Iran deal should stay he makes
as good a case as anyone of the
democratic party unless Congress or our
European allies figure out something
they can sell to trump as a fix
it seems that Trump is going to reimpose
sanctions on May 12th and if he does
that this deal could collapse and the
damage of that would be long-term and
potentially irreversible to set aside
the fact you would alienate a whole
generation of younger Iranians who
support this deal just think about what
this would do to America's credibility
why would North Korea consider signing a
nuclear agreement
with us if we just broke the agreement
we signed only three years ago with Iran
and if this deal dies and Iran receives
its nuclear weapons program it could
then start a nuclear arms race in the
Middle East and the problem here is I
can't offer you much hope there is not
really a write your Congressman solution
to this we could be in serious trouble
okay this is so stupid first of all the
younger generation of Iranians are not
in favor of the Iran deal because they
don't like the mullahs they want
anything that gets rid of them all they
may be in favor of a little bit more
economic growth in Iran but they're
certainly not in in thrall to the models
the same way that the American Left
seemed to be or the British left seem to
be or the European left seem to be it's
a pretty incredible argument also the
argument that it shreds our credibility
when we sign a nuclear deal with Iran if
we get rid of the nuclear deal no it
actually reimpose our credibility given
the fact that we know that they're going
to develop nuclear weapons and we're
putting the threat of sanctions and
military force back on the table right
that would be us saying to the North
Koreans listen guys we're not gonna sign
a fake deal with you we're not gonna do
with you what we did with Iran we're not
gonna pay you off so you can go and
cheat again but again the left is so in
favor of anything that President Obama
didn't sow against anything Trump does
that they're willing to ignore the fact
this Iran's goal was garbage at the
start the same left that's complaining
about human rights atrocities in Syria
funded with Iranian dollars is now
complaining that we should that we
shouldn't pull out of a deal that's
prevent that's giving those dollars to
Iran to go to Assad to be used for
genocide against people in Syria it's an
amazing amazing thing so the French are
over here making that case I don't think
that that case is going to go
particularly well thank goodness
president Trump has around him a very
good national security team at this
point John Bolton is his national
security adviser obviously he's got his
new Secretary of State Mike Pompeo or
soon to be Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo so all of that is is really good
the left's hysteria with regard to
everything Trump's done and is is so
overwhelming that it's leading them into
this box canyon of politics where
they're suddenly on the same side as the
mullahs which is just an amazing thing
but just goes to show you that there are
too many folks on the Left who are more
willing to make common cause with some
of the worst people on earth rather than
acknowledging that fighting the worst
people on earth might force them and
make common cause with people like
President Trump from time to time okay
time for some things I like and then
some things that I hate so the things
that I like so over the weekend I
watched the movie hostels this is one of
those films
where
it looked good in the theaters but I
knew I wasn't gonna be able to go see it
in the theaters because my wife would
never see this movie with me
it looked it's it's a bloody Western
with Christian Bale and Rosamund Pike
who is really a fantastic actress you
know it's it's a and she may be the best
actress out there right now
and the movie I think is probably the
best Western since Unforgiven I think
that's fair to say it's it's really dark
it is also kind of hopeful about the
nature of the human condition
it's very honest about what happened
between Native Americans and and white
Americans in in the West and it's it's
honest about the treatment of Native
Americans and it's also honest about the
brutality of Native Americans toward
white settlers in the West and this this
movie opens with Rosman Pike's entire
family being slaughtered by Native
Americans who raid her her house and
then kill her husband to her daughters
in her baby I mean it's pretty who's
pretty brutal stuff but again it doesn't
go easy on the Cowboys either so here is
a little bit of the preview know seeing
all the things you sing good all the
things you do
makes you feel thank you after a while
captain you do know she feel a walk the
army wants to be certain that the chief
gets home to Montana safely without
incident of any India
he's a butcher and the two of you oughta
get along just fine
I've killed savages divs that's my job
you have no idea what it does to men I
hate him I've got a war bag of reasons
to hate him this will be done and it
will be done by you parades over women
change so the movies really effective
and I think that it does again a really
good job of trying to draw it all sides
of the of the conflict here and it does
generate a fair bit of sympathy for for
everyone involved and does demonstrate
that there is bad blood on every side
and bad people on every side in this
particular conflict which is which is
well we're remembering and that people
do bad things but sometimes strive to
overcome the bad things that they've
done so again I really like the movie I
thought the movie is really really good
I'm surprised that it didn't get more
play in the press but I guess that
anytime you make a movie that isn't
Dances with Wolves about Native
Americans where it turns out that the
white guys are universally bad and the
Native Americans are universally good
then I guess that you get a lot of flack
for that so check out the movie it's
really it's really an interesting watch
I think ok time for a couple of things
that I hate so the radicalism of the
Democrats is on full display Kamala
Harris my senator from California she is
now making statements like assault
weapons need to be banned across the
country but she says this in probably
the least the least articulate way that
I've heard in quite a while to address
the fact again another false choice I'm
in favor of the Second Amendment and I
also want I want smart gun safety laws
assault weapons shouldn't be walking the
streets of a civilized country I agree
okay number one assault weapons aren't
walking the streets because people have
to be carrying them second of all you
generally can't carry a rifle around in
public and and third when she says that
she's in favor of the Second Amendment
but quote unquote assault weapons should
be banned everybody acknowledges that
when she talked when people talk about
banning assault weapons they really mean
removing virtually all operative rifles
in the United States it's it's really
amazing that the Left keeps they're just
being dishonest okay they're just being
dishonest at this point what the left
really wants the full gun ban they
should just argue for a full gun ban
because that's actually what they want
that's what they think would be a
active and so that's what I think would
be effective let's have that
conversation but they're not willing to
have that conversation instead they want
to have these little ancillary
conversations around the edges that will
have no impact on gun violence and will
simply be the predicate for a further
encroachment on American liberties
that's really what's going on here you
wanna know why people on the right you
know folks on the left listen to the
show you want to know why people on the
right think that you're going for a gun
grab because the conversation always
starts off like this folks on the Left
say we don't want your guns and you say
well you kind of do they say well we
just don't like a salt weapon you say
well you know assault weapons are
ill-defined what do you mean by that
semi-automatic weapon so what's
virtually every weapon in circulation in
the United States and they say well you
know that's okay you know we can take
the ones that will make it harder for
people to get them you say well what
about the ones already in circulation
then they say well we'll have to
probably take some of the ones away from
you people in the end anyway because we
have to get them out of circulation then
you say well what about revolvers
because those basically operate the same
way they just don't automatically load
the next round in the chamber they said
well yeah revolvers probably have to go
too and by the end of the conversation
you've come around to the idea that
there should be a full gun ban because
they believe in in the end they believe
that guns are responsible for the
violence they don't believe that some
types of guns are more responsible than
other types of guns because there's no
data to support that anyway so just
pointing out the stupidity here but you
know the the radicalism of the Democrats
is of course a feature not a bug for so
many on the Left al Sharpton says that
he wants to endorse Kamala Harris shock
of shocks the the demonstrative
intersectionality of the left continues
every single day al Sharpton a
legitimate piece of debris I mean al
Sharpton is a bad bad guy I mean this is
a guy who has participated in racial
hoaxes this is a person who has helped
legitimately incite violence I mean when
we talked about speech inciting violence
is a guy who went in front of a crowd
and accused people of murder who had not
committed murder and people in the crowd
were calling for violence I mean it was
Al Sharpton is a bad bad human and here
he is endorsing Kamala Harris just crazy
I felt a real passion from camel Harris
about really fighting for issues like
criminal justice as well as the economy
and other things and we made it clear
she was a prosecutor we may not agree on
everything
right but I think she really wanted that
audience who's from around the country
Civil Rights Act was okay so great al
Sharpton and Kamala Harrison one wing of
the party and the radicalism of the
party is only being united by their
hatred for a president Trump is one of
the reasons why the Democrats lost
election after election all the way up
till the point where Trump won the
presidency we'll find out whether
uniting around hatred for Trump is
strong enough to actually create
solidarity within the party okay we'll
be back here tomorrow tomorrow I will be
speaking at Lynch in in Lynchburg
Virginia at Liberty University at
convocation really looking forward to
that looking forward to seeing all the
students there should be a blast but
we'll see you here again tomorrow I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Applause]
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alexander Oh audio is mixed by
Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Joshua Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright floor publishing